[Music]
um
next year
wait till the talk
so yes the title of this project is
adaptive monopoly regulation and this is
based on joint work with jason hartline
and alex johnson at northwestern i
presented this uh two years ago at the
fox conference and what you're going to
see today is a new application and new
results that i'm presenting here for the
first time
i think this is a great place to present
these results for the first time
so
i'm going to start with an observation
which is that
economic conditions market conditions
can be very difficult to predict they
can change constantly and in fact
regulators seem to have difficulty
anticipating these changes in practice
so one example is the recent surge in
inflation the federal reserve does not
seem to have predicted the intensity or
the duration of the search
another example is the catastrophic
failure of the power grid in texas about
a year ago so the texas energy
regulators don't seem to have you know
anticipated the possibility of this kind
of weather event or prepared for it
properly
third example you know with the war in
ukraine natural gas prices have uh
spiked um and we see uh well we expect
that regulators probably didn't have a
perfectly accurate model of this
geopolitical event
and finally to take a local example
proposition 13 here in california passed
in the 1970s
i expect that voters in the 1970s did
not perfectly anticipate what housing
market conditions would look like in
california today
so with these motivations um the
high-level question that i'm going to be
pursuing
is can regulated markets adapt to
economic conditions
even if those conditions are
unpredictable and constantly changing
by
using access to market data and given
enough time
so in other words even if we're in a
wildly unpredictable environment that we
don't really understand can we still
regulate markets effectively using data
that regulators in practice are likely
to have access to and assuming we have
enough time to adapt
now i'm going to be pursuing this
high-level question in the context of
the particular application called
monopoly regulation okay and this is a
market where there's a single monopolist
uh maybe there are a lot of fixed costs
to entering the market and so you can't
have more than one firm
um the setting is uh one regulator one
firm and then uh consumers many
consumers so we can think about them as
arriving in sequence over time
now the tension in monopoly regulation
is that the firm cares about profits
while the regulator cares about welfare
we have the usual problems with market
power right so the firm is incentivized
to set prices uh
inefficiently high which is going to
sort of keep some consumers who might
value the product from getting it
in this kind of market you need to use
some kind of regulation in order to
get something approaching efficiency
now this problem has been studied before
you know famous paper by baron meyerson
uh took a mechanism design approach to
understanding this question
we're going to be taking an approach
that we call adaptive mechanisms
and the approach is done to bring
adversarial online learning
to mechanism design
some quality of the qualities of this
approach that i just want to highlight
we're not going to make any
distributional assumptions okay so if we
think about demand as evolving over time
we're not going to assume that it's id
we're not going to assume that it's
stationary or markovian or ergotic we're
not going to make any assumptions
whatsoever
we're not going to assume that the
regulator knows this uh distribution
we're not going to assume that the
regulator has detailed knowledge of the
firm's strategy
and we're not going to assume that the
firm has distributional knowledge
what we are going to do is introduce
solution concepts that neither exclude
the possibility that the firm has prior
knowledge nor require the firm to have
said prior knowledge and we're going to
design regulations that are effective in
a robust way given these solution
concepts
okay so what's the you know upshot what
what are we going to be able to actually
tell you about how to regulate markets
well we're going to propose what we call
customer first regulation okay and this
is a form of regulation that has you
know forms of it have been floated
before but it hasn't actually been
implemented in practice and i think
given the results that we have maybe we
should
so customer first regulation at a high
level is saying we want to incentivize
the firm to prioritize the well-being of
the customer
it's very simple we're going to have a
subsidy and a tax
the subsidy will be proportional to the
estimate of the consumer surplus in this
case 76 percent of consumer surplus will
be of estimated consumer surplus will be
offered as a subsidy to the firm
the tax is going to be 12 of the gross
profits that is profits before the
subsidies and for the taxes
now this is a pretty simple regulation
um and our environment is a very
adversarial one so the question is can
this possibly perform well
and somewhat surprisingly
our first theorem is going to say that
yes
customer first regulation guarantees 86
of the first best welfare
that's much better than other practical
forms of other forms of regulation used
in practice at least when applied to our
model
and this again is going to
uphold without requiring any prior
knowledge from either the regulator or
from the firm
now of course 86 for me is pretty good
um and there are many computer
scientists in the audience so i'm sure
they'll be okay with that but as an
economist i have to ask is this you know
the best uh is this the best we can do
um and the answer is uh close all right
so i'm gonna show in theorem2 that no
regulation is going to guarantee more
than 89 percent of first best welfare
and that's true even if the firm knows
the data-driven process
um so i actually i think we could
probably uh tweak the regulation to get
theor one to say 89 as well um but i
don't have that for you today
now you might wonder why are these
numbers so specific right
this is the theory talks um and
basically the results are going to
depend on some parameter the parameters
what's known as the shadow cost of
public funds we'll talk more about that
later
and i just
decide i just plugged in an empirical
estimate of that
okay cool uh so i'm going to skip over
related literature just in the interest
of time um but well we've seen even some
related literature today or you know
throughout this week at the workshop
um you know alex's uh paper on
incentivizing exploration is in there
or anything it's like calibrated on a
certain assumption for the structure of
the market
um it's going to be so we're going to
say that the regulator's regret relative
to a class of alternative strategies is
going to be low
but
if you look at the results what you'll
see is like
given whatever information the firm has
right
if you think about the first best as
being the regulator takes over the firm
and somehow is able to be as effective
as the firm in management and then
you're going to get 86 percent of that
as a guarantee
the parameters themselves come from data
to come from
the parameters as in like the demand and
costs and so forth those are going to be
a generated uh adversary oh adversary
okay all right
yes so so we'll get to that um not
necessarily so depending on the shadow
cost of public funds which is like an
exhaustion parameter you might run a
budget deficit or you might write a
budget surplus right
if you ask me to run not run a budget
deficit i'm not sure i'm not sure you
can get any kind of meaningful guarantee
here um but the idea here is and this is
sort of consistent with some uh earlier
work from tyrol and the front um the
idea is that we're going to model budget
constraint as being soft right so you do
you i you are able to fund finance a
budget deficit by sort of using taxes
elsewhere but those taxes elsewhere are
going to involve distortions and that's
going to be captured by this prem
so i think we have a pretty flexible way
of dealing with budget constraints but
we're not going to be imposing hard
budget constraints
okay
so let me talk about the model
so we're going to be dealing with a
repeated game
there's one regulator one firm and then
many consumers think about capital t
periods in each period one consumer
arrives
we're going to let capital t go to
infinity pretty soon
here's a sort of diagram that shows how
the game proceeds
you know at the beginning of period t
nature is going to choose some value for
the consumer vt this is like how much
you're willing to pay for the product
then the firm will set a price pt and a
level of effort e.t
effort is like managerial effort right
how hard is the co working to make sure
that the firm is running as efficiently
as possible
then the consumer will decide whether to
buy the product or not the quantity
purchased xt is just 0-1
then nature will choose the cost of
production or the cost of serving the
consumer
it's a cost function ct so it maps the
level of effort to some cost
and ct of et is like the realized cost
and then finally the regulator is going
to choose transfers for the
firm and then transfers to the consumer
f and tesla
yeah so um our model is going to allow
for the possibility that the firm is not
able to perfectly predict its costs
right so could not turn out that the
costs are a little bit higher than
expected um which makes sense i mean
we're talking about like each period is
one consumer but if you think about like
each period is one month you know it
could be that price fluctuations in that
month or cost fluctuations in that month
uh cause you're you know
possible to be different than expected
um but our results are still going to
allow for the possibility that the firm
is able to perfectly produce
so we're not going to be modeling that
but it's a very good point so what we're
going to assume is that the effort in
period t it might reduce your costs in
period t
but there's no spillover to mexico
okay so the regulator strategy sr is
going to map the observable history to
the transfers okay
what is the observable history well
basically everything not in gray
so you're going to observe the price the
sales and the realized costs which is
data that regulators in practice tend to
have access to at least in developed
countries you're not going to observe
the consumer's value you're not going to
observe the effort of the management and
you're not going to observe the cost
opportunities that we're not taking
advantage of sorry
yes
f would go into x
what is the effort
yes yes so c the cost is a function of
the effort
i get i just want to know what the
picture is
affecting the quantity of trade
the effort is coming into the costs so
you might it's always hard to see how
different is the room
but you see the second cost in black
there is ct applied to e2
so the actual costs that the firm pays
is going to depend on the effort
okay
so let's keep going okay let me know if
i can yeah
should we think of the cost as x t times
that so like there's only oh
yeah so the costs are only incredibly
certain so ah that's right
that's the effort in fact the sale
um
no but you know if you uh if you're the
firm and you put in a lot of effort and
for that reason you can reduce your
price then that might indirectly
but the effort is not going to like
increase the quality of the good it's
purely just going to affect the process
so conditional on price um
costs
so just because you only hate the cost
only the cost if there's a sale yes
okay
what is the transfer doing
the transfer we're going to use instead
of us
so we can think about taxes or subsidies
or penalties
what's the meaning of aspen
at this firm cs consumer
so it's transferred to
right now so the first strategy sm is
going to map the observable history to
prices and effort so um the
firm will decide what the prices are and
one thing they might take into account
is how much you have to do this i see
but they can determine the companies
it's not that the price depends directly
on them
not not directly although optimally for
the firm you don't want to you know if
you put really low effort your costs are
really high you don't want to set a low
price or the wise mind
yes
is
how how does the effort affect like i
understand effort affects cost is it is
the cost increasing in the effort
you don't need to say that you could but
you don't so i guess what is the
motivation for the firm to set a
particular effort like because you can
affect us so it could be that by putting
in high efforts costs
oh yeah no because i haven't told you
the objectives yet i know the firm's
going to have a disability
so that'll be the next slide yeah so the
iphone is great that means
so it's gonna so so far it's the
regulator there's no effort and then so
i'll just finish this portion of it so
the firm strategy is gonna map the
observable history for the firm
right the firm is gonna observe all the
things in black and also of course it's
has happened
so let me just uh get through the next
two slides that have a little bit more
structure and then take a few more
questions
so i mean assume that the regulator is
able to commit to its strategy that was
a lot i will tell you in dynamic
mechanism design commitment can be a
very strong assumption
i don't happen to think that our
solution relies that much of the
commitment assumption
but that's in a strong assumption we're
making
the
data generating process is the final
element that i want to use on this slide
so this is d this is the stochastic
process so like nature strategy that's
determining the customer's value from
the product and the cost function
i'm going to use acronym dgp for data
generating process just consistent with
you know what we do in economics
now two things i want to point out about
this in purple one is that the data
generating process is exogenous so no
actions taken by the firm or the
regulator are going to affect say the
future value of consumers
the second thing that i want to do is
sort of just stress that this is an
unrestricted data generating process
right so it does not need to be iid it
does not need to be more covenant it
does not need to be stationary
it's consistent with the adversarial
model of not my marketing
so i guess then does this rule out that
[Music]
um
i think uh because then
yeah so i guess uh that's
it is i suppose that's true that's not
the way that i would have thought about
the way that the model shuts down so the
quality investment but but that that's
right
the thing that i'm really like trying to
stress is this conscious thing is you
might imagine if the firm like
consistently says high prices that
different kinds of consumers will arrive
to the market than if you consistent
several tests
okay um
next i just need to define the
objectives for the firm and the
regulator
so the firm's objective
profit or what i'll call profit
it's going to be the expectation
according to the true data generating
process or ggp
time average of the following quantities
the revenue minus costs in green plus
the net transfers in purple minus the
this utility of effort attends the
previous question in revenue
now i'm including this utility of effort
in the profit
so maybe i should really call it the
firm's utility function but i'm just
going to call it profit for convenience
okay so that's the firm's objective the
regulator's objective is what we'll call
welfare and this is going to depend on
the parameters that i alluded to in the
introduction
so this shadow cost lambda of public
funds
and the idea here is as i suggested it's
basically a shadow
sorry a soft budget constraint okay so
the idea is
um you the regulator can run a budget
deficit in this market but you need to
finance that deficit using higher taxes
elsewhere those higher taxes are going
to lead to distortions and
inefficiencies in those other markets
and so we're going to think about for
every dollar of revenue that you need to
run this regulation you're going to pay
an additional social cost of lambda
dollars
right so if you set lambda to infinity
then you basically have a hard budget
constraint which actually may be loud i
can can address your question
um so we'll see that in a little bit um
but typically lambda is going to be much
smaller so the empirical estimate that i
gave you from like a 1976 jp paper the
lambda was like 16 cents
the other thing i want to highlight is
that this goes in both directions so
just as like the shadow cost exacerbates
the disadvantage of running a budget
deficit it's going to make it more
beneficial to have a budget surplus
right because if you have a surplus in
this market you can use that surplus to
reduce taxes elsewhere in the economy
and then you reduce those shadow costs
that you were paying before
now welfare we can finally define its
expectation given the true dgp
of the time average
of the following quantities so in green
is the total surplus so the consumer's
value minus the cost
the condition on the product being
bought
minus the disutility of effort so the
regulator is benevolent and cares about
the co being able to go to this kid's
baseball games
and then the shadow costs of transfers
which is incredible
okay um so let me know if there are any
questions um
the value is drawn from the distribution
so the data joining process which is a
stochastic process
and that's actually a great segue
because
you know this welfare depends on the tgp
just one second uh it depends on the ggp
of course the regulator this model does
not know what the dgp is so what we need
to do is quantify the uncertainty
of the regulator and sort of give you a
notion of how to think about what makes
a mechanism good in a robust sense and
consumers are myopic
consumers
even if xt is
so this is not like i am
saying that okay i'm gonna provide this
service and this is my proposal that
this is the cost and then you say okay
yes or no and then i put in there
[Music]
someone that's a great point um so yes
so we are going to be thinking about
um effort as in like
i'm working really hard this week to
make sure that you know all the factory
workers are working hard and then if we
don't end up selling anything that's
just some cause
um this utility of effort is just you
know this quantity here
and then the costs are so like when i
put an effort i don't necessarily know
how that's how that's going to affect
like the monitor costs of you know
did i fully answer questions
that was great
yeah that's it so
i mean it's a really nice way of using
the lambda but i was wondering in
practice
do you think it makes sense for it to be
symmetric for
like collecting and distributing funds
um you know i
i think it makes sense i mean that seems
like a
good way to understand and what are the
trade-offs associated with
groundbreaking deficits or surpluses and
like one market is going to be small
relative to full economy so it makes
sense to me that it'd be symmetric but
if you have a reason to think that it
should be asymmetric i'd love to chat
about it afterwards
yes
i'm really confused about the effort
because if the costs are
non-negative
then nobody benefits from uh
at all so why wouldn't the effort always
be zero
so uh they didn't answer the question
but so let's suppose you have a choice
between like putting in high effort
below first right if you put in high
effort then the cost of production are
going to be low right so you're going to
have some highest utility of effort but
it could be outweighed by the lower
energy costs
um if you've been lower then you might
have costs that are like perfectly fine
thrusts are not monotone and
0
but there's something
about the cost function so so i think
also i mean saying it now makes me
realize that maybe the term cost is
so there's like the dis utility which is
how unhappy is the manager
and then there's the cost which is
physically how much does the per have to
pay for this product right
and so you're trading up unhappiness as
a manager with like kid being
the only thing is that those kicks costs
uh discipline it's not simply observable
okay um so let me get to uh sort of
how does the regulator's quantified
uncertainty basically we're going to
follow the practice in uh on my learning
which is to think about the regulators
to define the regret into these two
ideas
first idea is an alternative
so we're going to consider a finite set
a of alternative regulator strategies
in particular we're going to assume that
these regula these alternatives are more
covalent
so here we're going to assume that the
transverse tau f and tau c only depend
on the observations in the previous
period
now
there's a reason for this assumption
there's a reason for this assumption
right
the reason for this assumption is
basically the typical reason and
statistics why we don't want to look at
a hypothesis space or class of experts
that's too rich right the overfitting
issue
so this is like something that we just
we have to do if you want to take a
cisco approach to this question
this assumption i think can be relaxed
significantly
um it just makes our solution concepts a
little bit more complex
it can't be fully relaxed but you know i
think it can be relaxed quite
substantially
next i want to introduce the idea of
solution concept yes
uh solution concepts these are
assumptions that we're going to be
making about agents behavior
so what do i mean by behavior i mean a
firm's response function
from a response function it's going to
be a map from the regulator strategy to
the firm strategy
um
think about like best response as an
example so best response says given the
true data changing process this is you
know uh
maximizing expected profits first
response is just a generalization of
general classes
a solution concept is going to map the
data generating process to a set of
responses that we view as plausible in
this critical setting
so for example if we want to take a
classical micro design approach and
solution concept would say
well given the data generating process d
we will assume that the firm
chooses a response that is the best
response given that
and then finally a solution to the
regulator's problem is going to pair a
regular strategy sr with the solution
concept sc
we go to the regulator and we say like
here's a solution for your problem you
need to do two things one we need to
tell you what regulations you use and
two we need to tell you uh what is the
solution concept that we're using to
motivate that convention
and we'll post more restrictions on the
solution concepts in the next section
okay finally we can talk about regular
regret and then we'll be done
so the red is going to be a function of
the regular strategy performance
response and data during process d
is going to be the difference between
the welfare under the optimal
alternative if you knew the dgpa and the
welfare under the rainbow strategy of
the one that it works
now of course that depends on for
example the gtp we don't know what that
is so we're going to think about regret
guarantees that hold for a given
solution
uh this is going to be the regret and
the limit as the number of periods grows
worst case over data generating
processes uh and a worst case level for
responses that are consistent with the
solution concept
so we're taking a very worst case
approach both with respect to the um
data generating process and with respect
to performance behavior um and we'll
think about asymptotic results
yes make sure i understand the solution
concept is itself worst case like
notion of equilibrium for this problem
so the solution concept uh so we haven't
said much about the solution concept yet
but it is going to be just some
assumption about how the agent behaves
and then we're going to be worst case
with respect to all behaviors that are
consistent with that solution concept
but you're going to specify one in
particular or one solution yeah or uh
yes that's true we will we will um but
it will become clearer in the next
section
yes those data actually
come
by field from this interaction
there yeah yeah sure
okay so what do we have in mind like at
the video so how often
every day every year
oh yeah so i'm going to take a very
very stylish approach which is like
every consumer that arrives is a new
period
but we'll think about
generalizing that
okay so that's it for the model um next
i want to talk about the axioms and
these are going to
basically restrict the set of solution
concepts
to
keep in mind of course when i say you
perform well i don't hate you for a
while period back period you know if
there's a shock there's a shock um but
you perform well
which
may be better than what we do in
practice as far as
okay axis um so the first axiom there's
gonna be three consistency
consistency says at a high level that
even an expert firm wants to satisfy the
solution concept okay so even if you
knew the dgp it would be in your best
interest to satisfy this concept
precisely uh basically um there exists a
firm's response within the solution
concept for any distribution d
that is that the best response
[Applause]
next uh it's the trackability answer so
this says that even an ignorant firm can
satisfy the solution concept
so even if you know nothing about the
gtp you're still able to sort of find
some algorithm that will satisfy the
solution concept
it says that there's a response fee
where the fee is consistent with the
solution concept for ndd
finally
this is the strongest accent
that's the margin justifiability
justifiability is going to be strong
restriction on the solution concept and
what it's going to mean is that our
results are strong right it's going to
sort of tie our hands and
keep us from throwing out or ruling out
behaviors of the firm um without like
really good points
so
verbally we're going to say that we only
rule out behavior that even an ignorant
firm that knows nothing about the dgp
can see it will be eventually dominated
let me give you the definition more
precisely
for every firm's response that is
excluded by the sufficient concept for
some distribution
there exists some deviation utilda
where the following three problems hold
first is that that deviation is
consistent with the solution concept for
nddg
second is that this deviation is no less
profitable than the original in the
limit as the number of periods grows for
any dgp
third is that the deviation is strictly
more profitable than the original limit
for the true vg
so what does this mean it works
well one says that even an ignorant firm
will be able to identify this deviation
tim says that even an ignorant firm
would be convinced that this deviation
is uh going to be
leaving no result and three says that
actually they would have been
i'm
okay because i i said it to be a subset
yeah if you're explicit about that you
want to go all possible okay
yeah can you clarify why what you mean
by ignorant here for the firm ignorant
means that the firm knows nothing about
the data type process
does not know scripty or does not know d
prime
so i practice just uh sort of any
whatever abstract object d is the true
dtp and so the firm does not know the
truth
and also just the the firm knows scripty
but again scripty is just a set of all
stickers processes so
it doesn't require any dollars
yes and he's actually satisfied by
natural solution concepts that can you
construct social concepts to satisfy oh
yeah
i i'm increasingly thinking that i won't
be able to tell you what this is but i i
think of them
uh i
don't think i'll need to um so the
strategy the so just in the strategy
itself
is not going to enter um so
i guess if the question is for like the
consistency axis might need to talk
about what the best response is what
optimality is um
and so there i don't think it's gonna be
an issue
but yeah so i don't see that issue
arising but maybe we can chat after
listening let's see
okay so uh just a quick proposition it
turns out that this third accident
applies to those two so it's really much
stronger
but it's still good that we cover the
first two and the first one will come up
again
okay so main results uh the results i
already told you what they are kind of
but here's more obsessive m1 says that
there exists a justifiable solution
concept
where the regulator's direct guarantee
is
this
and this is a coefficient that depends
on the shadow cost lambda times the
maximum value so it's an upper bound on
consumer stuff
this if you plug in an estimate of the
shadow cost that comes from purple paper
uh you will get that this is 14 of the
maximum
so the regret is the most fortunate
the question is of course can we do
better and this leads us to zero two
there two says that there is no
consistent solution
where the regulation back guarantee is
lower than this weird function of one
times the maximum value which again
corresponds 11 percent under a
reasonable amount of development
so we could get down from 14 to 11 if we
you know look at consistent solution
concepts and keep my consistency is a
much weaker condition than
justifiability um
but
that's it
and as i would it's earlier i think we
could probably
purchase that okay
how is the maximum value defined was it
just the false
maximum value which i didn't mention
earlier but this is an upper bound
yeah i don't think um i mean if the cost
is super high then uh
the best you can do is nothing right
so i don't think we need any kind of ban
on it
you have control over your actions as a
firm but you can't control your values
so let me say something that i'm not
sure i understood that response um
which is uh i might be leaving myself um
but if you think about the cost of like
you know producing a car to be like
million dollars right then you're not
going to regret
any given regulation because whatever
you do no one will buy the card right
um so the market blowing is the same way
so uh the nation program is that we only
as you know right we only care about um
you know doing well in settings where
it's possible to do well i'm happy to
talk more afterwards too
okay um so we're gonna drop theorem two
and just think about theorem one and i
just wanna at a high level tell you what
the steps are that you need to prove a
theorem like this
first step is familiar we need to ask
what does a regulator do
in this case we need to construct a
strategy for the regulator
then we need to ask what does the firm
do
so we need to construct a solution
concept for the firm
typically a mechanism design question
two is like straightforward right we
know okay the firm best response in this
case we need to do a little bit more
step three is the really interesting new
step
we need to ask
so we asked what does the firm do and
now we need to ask how does the firm do
this and why should it
now economists were really good at sort
of saying like why should the firm
behave in a particular way right we're
really good at understanding incentives
and computer scientists are really good
at understanding how do you accomplish
something like how can you actually come
up with an algorithm that will achieve
this solution concept
and we can address both questions by
showing that a solution is justifiable
uh finally we can um ask how well does
regulator do which is lower bounding the
welfare under the proposed strategy
and then we can ask how well could the
regulator have done which is upper
bounding welfare under the regulator's
alternative
now today uh i think a lot of time so
we'll talk about what the regular
strategy is
i don't think we'll have time to go
through the solution concept but uh i'm
happy to talk about it some other time
or offline
and then we definitely won't have time
to open this
yes
it's this axiom that i uh
all i mentioned for you
okay so regular strategy again i
basically told you about this
introduction
uh it's customer first regulation we
have a tax and sales
the tax is going to be on surplus which
is revenue minus costs the subsidy is
going to be based on the consumer
surplus which is just the
value minus costs value minus price
conditional annual purchase
that is not quite linear right the
regulator money is worth less than the
other player's money is that right
and the idea is that if you if you get a
budget surplus you can reduce taxes
elsewhere and reduce those associated
solutions
uh the net transfers confirmed under
this mechanism are going to be something
proportional to an estimate cs hat of
the consumer surplus minus something
proportional to user surface
the estimate has to be unbiased and
we'll talk about that on the next slide
um okay so just the thing to notice of
course this will depend on lambda right
in the extreme case for lambda is equal
to zero
uh the subsidy will be 100
and then the tax will be zero as you
increase lambda you're going to reduce
the subsidy and you're going to increase
the tax
in the limit
you'll have no subsidy because you can't
afford it and the tax will be fifty
percent
so you
you won't have a finite regret guarantee
but you will still get like a
like fifty percent of uh a notion of
first quest
so you you said this ensure what does
the regulator observe and why
so it doesn't observe e3 but it observes
ctet yes it observes the realized cost
but not the effort that went into it it
can look into the books of the firm
exactly right it observes the price of
the sales it does not observe so prices
sales variation of the customers
okay so how do we get that estimate um
so the estimate is
basically gotten by experimenting on
consumers but we're experimenting in
like a lightweight so we're
experimenting a way that's always better
for the firm type of consumer to
participate
we're going to offer a randomly selected
consumer money to not purchase the
product
more precisely what we're going to do is
for every consumer that arrives with
probability epsilon we will select them
for experiment
then we will uh offer that will decide
on some quantity of money drawn
uniformly and then we'll tell the
consumer hey if you don't buy the
product we're gonna offer you that
remember
what does this look like in practice
well think about you know you own a home
you pay an election bill
someday you get an email from your local
electricity regulator and they say if
you reduce your consumption next month
by 20 you're gonna offer you a hundred
dollars
it's not that
right
uh the estimated consumer surplus is the
following quantity um which i'll just
leave that there for a moment
and say that the estimated consumer
surplus is supplies
okay great
so i just want to briefly talk about the
incentives um that this regulation
offers at a high level
so the incentives for pricing are
actually going to be efficient so firm's
going to set efficient prices and this
is because this regulation aligns sort
of the regulator firmness value from an
additional dollar producer surplus with
um you know their value from uh
additional monthly slanted consumers
if land is zero the prices will maximize
total surplus
if land is going pretty much the prices
will eventually maximize the producer
surplus and the idea here is that
their
value for money is the government is so
high
uh that you know what you want to do is
generate as much tax revenue as possible
which comes from producer surplus
and the way basically what you're doing
is you're getting the firm to extract
tax revenue
okay um next can send us your effort
those are not going to be as good for
fundamental reasons so the regulator and
firm are going to disagree on sort of
the trade-off between a dollar saved and
effort and uh plus a hundred dollars to
weigh into the surplus
the firm will generally put in too
little effort
um when lambda is zero uh
that won't be an issue will put an
efficient effort the land is small
you'll still fit almost efficient effort
as long as infinity will skip effort as
long as the return on investment is
below
you could improve effort incentives by
just increasing the
lowering the
taxes on profit
that's just a surplus
but that means that you have less money
in your hands which if lambda is high
then you value that that factor
okay um so now uh i will talk about the
solution concept i imagine about three
triple
um before
okay very nice
i think all right
um so let me just quickly talk about a
solution concept which is not the one we
use and describe why it is not good
that's it okay so you might be familiar
with no regret assumptions
uh let me take a simple example to
illustrate why the assumptions are not
uh good enough for ourselves
in period one uh you have a high value
because
you have a median value at a low value
then you get high media low high inflow
so we're just assuming that this is the
data driven process for the purpose of
illustration
we're going to assume zero costs to just
shut down that
a first strategy is no direct if
deviating to a fixed price p cannot
improve the long run profits
now i wanted to show you a few examples
of firm strategies and categorize them
by whether they satisfy notable
the first one is when the firm always
sets low press
and well you know two thirds of the time
the value of the consumer is medium or
high so let's just suppose that the
parameters are such that setting a low
price is not the best thing to do we
prefer to always set a median price for
a set of high prices
so this is going to be positive regret
it will be moved
um now median price always
that will be zero rep we're just going
to assume the transfer values are such
that setting always media price is
better than setting always the highest
so here you have zero event
this
is well look for this
third we have the case where the firm
appears to be able to perfectly predict
the consumer's value so you have a high
price and mean price and low price high
medium low time
now here you're doing like the very best
you could with like a ton of information
so certainly you don't want to fix you
make some fixed strategy because you'll
be thrown away
so here you're going to actually get
negative regret and you're going to be
consistent with your number
so this line here kind of looks like the
nerf firm that doesn't really know much
about the data generating process it
doesn't understand that it's like
repetitive
but they're still doing okay
this looks like a
very well advanced that knows the key
the final example is one that i want to
focus on suppose with the firm every
third period sets a low price sorry it's
a high price but otherwise that's
immediate price
now here
this behavior is going to satisfy our
regret the reason is whenever you set a
media price you're doing just as well as
the median price always whenever you
said high price well even if you
deviated to always setting median price
you wouldn't sell to low value consumer
savings
so you're gonna get no regret
but it's weird right it's weird because
you know you like clearly you understand
that every third period is different
from the upwards like clearly you can
sort of understand there's something
special about every third period but
you're using this information in exactly
the wrong way you're setting high prices
when you should set low prices
right so you have this information but
you're using it in grammar
and that's what no regret lost and we
need to move on and in fact we can show
that if you only assume no regret
it's not possible to get any kind of
meaningful
guarantee for the regular so not only
does this behavior look weird than
irrational but actually it's going to be
pathological
calibration is going to fix this
particular issue but it's not going to
fix another issue and what that speaks
to that other issue that i haven't told
you about is counterfactual calibration
this is that operation
counterfactual calibration
i'll not go through that but basically
this is a new solution concept that we
developed in the fox paper um that
resolves its kind of issues
okay now i will conclude
um at a high level how do i see this
work well
let's go back 50 years and talk about
classical mechanisms design
i would characterize this kind of work
as leading to promising but fragile
methods
promising because when they work they
work really well
but fragile because they only work in a
limited set of departments
the bus making design let's serve about
20 years ago is robust it works in a
large number of environments but it's
conservative right and it doesn't
necessarily work particularly well in
any given
auction design is a special case auction
design robust mechanisms can work really
well
um but settings like persuasion uh
contract design or monopoly regulation
generally you're going to have a
significant loss
the idea of adaptive mechanism science
is whether we can use data a new
resource to get mechanisms that are
really promising and
so they work in a large variety of
settings and they get good guarantees in
all those things
in this paper we applied that mechanism
design to monopoly regulation
and deliver foundations for what we call
customer burst regulation
uh there's some more to do we need to
tighten up the results uh get richer
sets of alternatives and hopefully to
have something to say about the final
verizon problem
but more generally i think this is an
interesting framework uh hopefully you
can give us some insights and i'd love
to see it apply to other
sites yes so i guess this is so you
didn't
actually say that
so it could be possible that the optimal
policy for the regulator actually leads
to negative
earnings it may be that the regulator
has to
invest in the product
[Music]
like put money into that
i guess you do put money into the market
in the sense that if you run a bunch of
deficit then you're pretty much but so
what this is saying is
even in that case you're close to me
or you're close to the optimal so
so it's saying that like if your costs
of funds
are low um
if you can tax very efficiently right
then
what's talking
through subsidies and then you get
efficiency um if you have more costly
taxation elsewhere then you don't want
to put as much subsidies but you still
want to have some combination right
yes
um yeah so uh lumi and gula and aaron
maya have a paper maybe you know about
the last monopoly regulation um so
they're not taking the adaptive approach
they just say let's assume that the
raven knows nothing about demand and
costs
they are assuming that the foreign costs
but it's just a one-shot game so there's
no
learning
and they show that you know uh depending
on how much you relatively value the
loose reverse consumer surplus you get
some robust version of
verifiers
the idea here is of course that when we
have a repeated game we have access to
additional data additional information
we can uh hopefully do better than just
yes you said consumers
it's it's subsidizing people not to
purchase the product no no it's it's
subsidizing the firm
uh
to make the customers happy
so if the firm you know sets lower
prices for instance that's going to make
the customers happy because we have more
than just circles and we're going to
offer the from a subsidy that's
proportional
uh
so uh
the kinds of regulations that i'm aware
of are most like cost plus the rate of
return regulation where you're
basically compensating the firm for the
cost that it occurs uh but if there are
regulations that look like this i'd be
very curious
it's a way
if
that's right that's right yeah so in one
case you can say well you know we'll
just barely cover your costs and the
issue with that in this case is that if
you just barely cover someone's costs
they're not going to have any incentive
to put in
right so we've got a lot of firms with
managers that aren't really
running their competition yeah
so
that university focuses
useful
surveyed
another version it's like can you design
all those algorithms satisfying your
mission
yeah um so what i would say is so two
things one is for the regulator the
actually the regulation doesn't have to
learn anything right let's do this
uh the firm does have to work the front
of us after that
and we don't really study um sorry
it's okay so in principle yes it just
observes you know
customers every now and then
together
the
convergence might be effective right um
rate of convergence finance advance and
so forth we haven't talked about it at
all i'm hoping we'll be able to say
something interesting about that uh i
think you might be able to um but
it will require uh relaxing or
justifiability because that's inherently
asymptomatic
so we have like this trade-off but like
if we want to say something finance
sample we need to make the solution
concepts a little bit less like
compelling for toxins
all right i think we can take the rest
of the questions